So, ist schon irgendjemand da? Mein zweiter Rechner ist gerade abgekackt, wo ich die Stream-Vorschau habe.
Kann mir jemand sagen, ob wir Quality Options haben? Wobei, ich kann einfach nachgucken, ob wir Quality Options haben.
Ah, nee, kann ich nicht, weil ich die Desktop am anderen Rechner stecken habe. Na, auch geil. Wieder umstöpseln.
Gucken, ob wir Quality Options haben. Gleich mal Ton aus.
Ah, wir haben Quality Options. Da gesellt sich zu den Broggers ein Poggers. Quality Options, nice.
So, ich muss mich erstmal wieder auf dem anderen Rechner anmelden. Ich sehe gerade keinen Chat.
Falls das überhaupt schon alles richtig live ist auf Twitch, ja, ist es ja.
Ich gucke jetzt mal den Chat, in der Zeit bis mein zweiter Rechner gestartet ist.
So, das sieht schon besser aus.
Kann das sein, dass der Sound irgendwie weg ist?
Ah, jetzt. So, jetzt ist der zweite Rechner auch da. Jetzt kann es ja langsam losgehen.
Ich habe jetzt den Namen da schon öfters gesehen, weil Twitter ja immer zwischendurch anzeigt, wenn du refresht, wer folgt und wer nicht folgt.
Und Twitter zeigt mir in letzter Zeit irgendwie immer an, Blue Bash folgt und entfolgt und folgt und entfolgt und folgt.
Erwischt.
Der Sebaro ist auch am Chat. Ja, ich habe extra für dich Quality Options angemacht. Nicht, dass ich da Einfluss drauf hätte.
Telekom hat das Internet gefixt. Wie fixen die Telekom das Internet? Also bei mir schafft es die Telekom nicht.
Ich habe vor, ich bin jetzt ja letztens erst von Unity Media zur Telekom gewechselt.
Und jetzt überlege ich ernsthaft, weil die Telekom so viele Probleme hat mit allen möglichen Seiten, einfach weil die Verbindung lahm ist dorthin.
Und weil bei mir auch das Sync vom DSL Modem irgendwie ab und zu mal abreißt, geht mir echt auf den Sack.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich jetzt nicht wieder von der Telekom nächstes Jahr zu Unity Media wechsle.
Also ich meine, ich bin ja immer noch bei Unity Media, weil ich das Kündigen verpasst habe.
Das heißt, ich könnte eigentlich Telekom wieder kündigen und dann Unity Media machen, weil wir haben jetzt bei Unity Media, gibt es jetzt was Neues, habe ich gesehen, das ist für mich gut.
Also aktuell kriege ich bei der Telekom VDSL 100 und kann upgraden auf 250. Das kostet aber mal ordentlich Geld.
So, ich zeige euch das mal. Das kostet, das kostet, das ist übelst teuer.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Ja, Unity Media, ein Gigabit geht nicht. Da wohne ich einen Ticken zu weit weg, einen Tick.
Guck mal, ob es da eine Karte gibt.
Ich wohne nicht direkt in Frankfurt, ich wohne ein bisschen neben Frankfurt.
Und es geht nicht, es geht nicht so weit.
Also bei der Telekom ist das höchste der Gefühle, was ich kriege aktuell.
Warum müssen diese Seiten eigentlich so übelst unübersichtlich sein? Kann mir das mal irgendjemand erklären?
Zuhause.
Internet und DSL. Also das höchste der Gefühle, was ich kriege ist das da.
So, für 55, also aktuell bezahle ich das, 45 Euro. Und das heißt, dann müsste ich 10 Euro mehr bezahlen.
Bei der Telekom. So, da kriege ich max, da kriege ich 250, 40. Mit dem großen Vorteil, ich kriege einen vollwertigen DualStack Anschluss.
Das kriegen wir bei Unity Media nicht hin, weil sie einfach zu wenig IPv4 Adressen haben.
Also bei der Telekom würde ich 250 down, 40 abkriegen, ein richtiger DualStack.
Mit dem Problem, dass, ich muss mir das jetzt mal aufschreiben, sonst vergesse ich das nämlich wieder.
Also, Telekom gibt es 250 down, 40 ab für 55 Euro im Monat.
Das Problem bei der Telekom ist, DSL Sync manchmal weg.
Und das andere Problem bei der Telekom ist, Kackverbindung zu Twitch, YouTube und ande.
Das ist zwar ganz viel, das ist wirklich ätzend mit der Telekom. Ich muss manchmal echt umschalten auf Unity Media, dass ich überhaupt manche Sachen angucken kann, wenn viel los ist.
So, das ist Telekom. Also das hier ist Kon Telekom.
Pro Telekom ist eindeutig ein richtiger DualStack.
Da sieht man wieder, was das für eine Scheiße ist. Es gibt eigentlich nichts richtig Gutes in Deutschland von mir.
So, und wenn wir jetzt bei Unity Media gucken, haben wir nämlich was Neues.
Alter, wie mir diese Scheiße, das auf jeder Seite, hat da nicht schon mal einer einen Browser Plugin oder so entwickelt, was diese komischen Pop-Ups standardmäßig akzeptiert.
Weil ich meine, es ändert doch eh nichts großartig dabei. Ich block doch eh fast alles.
So, und bei Unity Media kriege ich... Okay, fairness halber müssen wir das hier vergleichen.
Aber ich brauche ja eh Unity Media für Fernsehstells. Also nicht für mich, aber ist das so, ist das halt, ja.
Ich finde das immer geil, wie sie hier oben rumstelzen. Dabei kostet dich das nur eins von zwei Jahren, wo du gebunden bist.
Also du bist sicher noch ein zweites Jahr dabei, wo du dann das bezahlst. Das ist halt halbe knackt.
Ach ja, und übrigens, was hier nicht dabei steht, ist... Genau, das kommt nämlich noch dabei.
Das kommt nämlich noch dabei, das darf man nicht vergessen.
Der Kabelanschluss, der muss noch dazu bezahlt werden. Also in Wirklichkeit sind das, und jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Das sind quasi, gucken wir mal. Gut, hier ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Aber ich meine, ich brauche ja im Prinzip den Kabelanschluss zum Fernseh... Moment, der ist ja nicht dabei.
Warum ist der Kabelanschluss denn nicht dabei? So wird er voll behindert.
Was genau ist denn der Vorteil davon jetzt?
Ich meine... Hä? Die Preisgestaltung ist komisch.
Kein Kabelanschluss notwendig, ok. Ja, aber ich brauche ja einen Kabelanschluss, damit meine Mutter Fernseh gucken kann.
So... Ich gucke ja kein Fernseh.
Das ist bescheuert.
Nee, der gehört nicht. Ach so, doch, ich muss den dabei bezahlen, weil der Kabelanschluss mir gehört.
Ähm... Moment, wo ist denn jetzt da der Unterschied? Kann mir das jetzt mal irgendeiner... Checkt das irgendeiner?
Also hier brauche ich... Voraussetzung ist ein Kabelanschluss von Unity Media.
Wenn ich jetzt aber... Nur mal so, ne? Hier muss ich den Kabelanschluss dabei bezahlen.
Ja klar, du musst... Dass du Unity Media... Dass du Fernseh gucken kannst, zumindest Unity Media Anschluss.
Obwohl der Kabelanschluss im Keller ist, musst du Geld bezahlen.
Da musst du dir diesen Basisfernsehtarif holen. Wie gesagt, ich brauche ja eigentlich keinen Fernseh.
Aber meine Mutter will Fernseh gucken.
Meine Mutter wurde im Erdgeschoss und die ist da ganz scharf drauf.
Und der gehört letztendlich auch das Haus. Was wir... Das habe ich vor ein paar Jahren im Video gezeigt. Das haben wir ja geerbt, beziehungsweise vom Opa.
Und da haben wir gesagt, warum sollten wir den Krams verkaufen, wenn man doch ein Haus hat?
Das ist eigentlich irgendwie ein Anliegen. Am Anfang wollte ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ey lass den Scheiß verkaufen, ich bleibe in meiner Wohnung.
Aber dann habe ich mir Gedanken darüber gemacht, dass das so deutlich angenehmer ist.
Erstens die Lage zum Bahnhof ist viel besser und die Nachbarn sind mir in der alten Wohnung übelst auf den Sack gegangen.
Das habt ihr teilweise... Ihr habt... Das kennt ihr noch früher aus den Videos, wo die Kinder rumgeschrien haben.
Wo ich Fenster teilweise im Sommer aufhab, wo die Kinder unten rumgeschrien haben, wo sie dann irgendwie Krankenwagen gespielt haben und ins Haus gerannt sind.
Alter, die Kinder sind mir auf den Sack in der alten Wohnung.
Tja, da habe ich gesagt, warum nicht? Ziehen wir ins Haus vom Opa.
So, und zumindest habe ich gesagt, ich bezahle das ganze Internet-Zeug.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Nö, also jetzt gehen mir die Nachbarn nicht auf den Sack.
Die letzten Nachbarn echt in Ordnung, kann ich nicht sagen.
Wir haben einmal als Nachbarn eine türkische Familie mit irgendwie vier oder fünf Kindern oder so.
Aber die haben die ganz gut im Griff, außer dass die Kleinen ab und zu mal rumschreien, passiert da eigentlich nichts.
Und auf der anderen Seite wohnt auch eine Familie mit drei...
Ne, zwei oder drei Kinder, ich glaube drei Kinder.
Also die gehen übelst ab, die produzieren alle Nachwuchs ohne Ende.
Aber die halten alle die Klappe, die sagen nichts.
Was ich immer lustig finde teilweise von unseren türkischen Nachbarn,
du siehst ja doch mal den ein oder anderen auf der Straße.
Und die sind nicht ganz so konservativ, da darf die Frau auch alleine raus.
Und es ist aber witzig, wenn du da vorbei läufst, zum Eingang,
und sagst dann irgendwie Hallo oder sowas, die guckt dich nicht an.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das verboten ist, fremde Männer anzugucken,
oder ob sie Demo zeigen muss, keine Ahnung, die guckt mich nie an.
Ich dachte, hallo, noch vorbei.
Und die sagt dann zwar auch Hallo, aber guckt dann so demonstrativ irgendwo so schräg an einem vorbei.
Ich dachte, hä?
Aber gut, wenn das so ist.
Sie wird wahrscheinlich dementsprechend erzogen, als ich das so gehört.
Ja, oh, übrigens Fortnite, kennt ihr dieses, das ist übelst.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz, ich suche das mal auf Twitter kurz raus,
aber das mache ich auf einem anderen Rechner,
weil auf Twitter findet man sonst Dinge, wo man instant gebannt wird,
wenn ich das in die Suche eingebe.
Das da, ey, Alter, Kinderschei, Kinderkacke, ey, wartet mal, guckt es euch mal an, ey.
Von wegen Fortnite, Fortnite ist das neue Kot, was das angeht.
Achtung.
Alter, die kleinen Pisse.
Ich, okay, ich höre mich übelst kinderfeindlich an, ich weiß, ja.
Aber, Alter, das ist doch nicht normal.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Oh, das tut weh.
Maxer Kinderhass war wieder am Start, ey.
Ich finde, das ist übelst, das ist einmal übelst cringe, so übelst Fremdschirm,
und auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir so, äh, so sein, ey.
Das ist wirklich komplett Ripp, ey, guckt es euch mal an.
Die sind, wie alt sind die, keine Ahnung, irgendwie, äh,
warum wird das eigentlich größer, wenn man die Seite kleiner macht?
Quickmaps auf YouTube, guckt mal.
Aber das, das, das ist YouTube, Logan, guckt mal.
Ich mache größer und das Video wird kleiner.
Erst ab 300% wird das Video größer und die Seite, der Hintergrund geht weg,
weil YouTube, so, und das Video, das richtig größer wird,
das Video nur, wenn ich die Seite kleiner mache.
Ich meine, keine Ahnung, was sind die?
Fünf?
Ja, sind die fünf?
Alter, das ist, oh, das tut weh.
Das, das, das schmerzt beim Zugucken.
Das tut echt weh.
Äh, so, wir waren bei Internet-Anbietern, ähm,
bevor wir dann noch ein bisschen Progas machen noch.
Ja, also, so ganz habe ich das ja nicht verstanden.
Guck mal, das hier kostet 60 Euro im Monat
und ich muss noch einen Kabelanschluss dabei bezahlen,
was nochmal 20 Euro sind.
Also bezahle ich 80 Euro im Monat für Fernseh, Internet und Telefon.
So, wenn ich jetzt 2playfly400, auch schon geiler Name, nehme
und den normalen Kabelanschluss dabei,
dann bezahle ich 70 Euro im Monat.
Warum sollte ich fly400 nehmen?
Versteht das irgendjemand?
Warum kostet das hier unter dem Strich 10 Euro mehr im Monat als das?
Es kann sein, dass der Kabelanschluss über die Mietnebenkosten bezahlt wird.
Nein, wird er nicht.
Also, ich bezahle ihn ja.
Der wird garantiert nicht über die Mietnebenkosten bezahlt.
Außerdem sind wir ja nicht in Miete hier.
Aber ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich meine, guckt mal, im Prinzip, das hier, das hier ist für,
das ist ja fake, was hier steht.
Hier müssten eigentlich 80 Euro stehen.
70 Euro für Internet, Fernseh, Telefon.
Und hier rechnen wir hier das drauf.
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Warte mal, Details, Details.
Okay, Details, Details.
Vermiete einfach an dich selber.
Ja, dann kann ich den Kabelanschluss in den Mietnebenkosten bezahlen.
Big brain, das ist massive.
Lul.
Bei einem ist kein Fernsehen in HD dabei.
Doch, klar.
Doch.
Das steht hier halt nicht.
Weil hier ist, also, noch mal zu mitschreiben.
Das hier ist das Angebot nur Internet und Telefon.
Dazu kann man sich aber den Basisanschluss holen.
Der kostet 20 Euro von Unity Media.
Und da ist halt alle öffentlich-rechtlichen in HD dabei.
Deswegen sind wir hier bei 70 Euro.
Und hier ist quasi das offizielle Fernseh-Internet ohne Horizon.
Ja, wozu brauche ich eine Horizon Box?
Die wollen ernsthaft 10 Euro im Monat mehr für so eine komische Horizon Box?
Wozu? Ich habe überhaupt keine Verwendung für eine Horizon Box.
Verstehe.
Also, das heißt, im Endeffekt, Unity Media kriege ich dann...
Ah, Moment, ich muss noch eine Sache.
Ich muss noch Power-Upload zurechnen.
Das kostet natürlich auch Bonus.
Das kostet noch mal 3 Euro im Monat.
73 Euro.
Gut, da ist es.
Das stimmt nicht.
Hier muss ich das wieder abziehen.
Ich bezahle 53 Euro, weil unter dem Strich 20 Euro für Kabelanschluss mit ZDF, ARD, HD muss ich immer bezahlen.
Egal, ob ich Telekom oder Unity Media nehme.
Immer.
Also, für 53 Euro kriege ich bei Unity Media im Endeffekt mit Power-Upload, das ist mit 40, da kriege ich dann quasi 400 down und 40 up.
Was eigentlich viel besser ist.
Das große, das Pro bei Unity Media ist allerdings, das ist bei mir, das trifft jetzt überhaupt nicht global zu.
Bei mir ist Unity Media viel stabiler als die Telekom.
Man kann mit der Horizon Box irgendwie, das ist aber hier gar nicht drin, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Hier sind auch nur die öffentlich-rechtlichen drin.
Ach ne, doch Pro 7 HD.
Ne, das ist Horizon TV.
Hier sind auch nur die öffentlich-rechtlichen drin.
Oder?
Ne, das ist hier schon dabei, oder?
In Horizon TV bereits enthalten.
Ah, das bezahlt man hier damit.
Aber das Problem ist, das Problem dabei ist ja, was die immer nicht erzählen, dass quasi alles, das ist auch so ein Fail-Gebiet in Deutschland.
Alles außer öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehsender in HD zu empfangen ist absolut Cancer.
Öffentlich-rechtliche zu empfangen in HD ist gut, da ist nichts verschlüsselt oder sonst was.
Aber versucht mal, was einem da in den Weg gestellt wird, und das ist aktuell auch gar nicht möglich so ohne weiteres.
Irgendwie bestimmt, aber mir ist keine funktionierende Lösung bekannt, wie man quasi private HD-Sender empfangen kann, außer mit dem offiziellen Empfänger.
Und ich will das nicht mit dem offiziellen Empfänger machen.
Wenn ich das mit dem offiziellen Empfänger an einem Fernsehen in einem Raum machen will, das will ich nicht.
Ich will das ganz normal aufnehmen, auf mein Nass, und dann im Endeffekt von allen Clients, die es gibt, gucken können.
Nee, und nicht so ein Scheiß mit der offiziellen Box.
So, also das heißt, bei mir ist Unity Media viel stabiler.
Und Con, das ist halt relativ big, das ist Dual-Stack-Light.
Und Carrier-Crate-Nut, wie kürzt man das eigentlich ab?
C-G-Nut, keine Ahnung, Dual-Stack mit Carrier-Nut.
So, das ist das Riesen-Con bei Unity Media.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass immer mehr Seiten über IPv6 erreichbar sind.
Und, jetzt kommt der große Knackpunkt im Vergleich zu ein paar Jahren, ist auch das komplette Telekom-Mobile-Netz mittlerweile IPv6.
Das heißt, ich kann ohne Probleme VPN vom Handy heim machen über IPv6, und das funktioniert dann.
So, das sagt Balls.
Ich habe aktuell Unity Media lang genug genervt, dass mein Anschluss umgestellt wurde auf klassisches IPv4.
Aber ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus, wenn ich jetzt hier was umstelle, upgrade oder sonst was, stellen die den Shit wieder um.
Garantiert, weil die haben einfach nicht genug Adressen.
Kannst du die Cons für Noobs erklären?
War es das da? Dual-Stack-Light-Carrier-Crate-Nut?
Oder, oder die, nein, die Cons, also, ok, du meinst die Unity Media Cons.
Mach ich, kann ich dir erklären.
Kannst du nicht über Business Anschluss einen IPv4 bekommen?
Doch, Sebaro, kann ich.
Die Sache ist die, dort ist, ich überlege gerade, wie das war.
Genau, dort gibt es kein Fernsehzeug.
Also, du musst, du musst bei Business quasi viele Sachen noch mal zusätzlich bezahlen.
Mal gucken wir mal.
Falls ich vergesse, erinnere mich gleich noch mal dran, undesputet, ich erkläre das gleich noch mal, was das ist.
Weil hier gibt es ja im Endeffekt nur Office, Internet und Phone.
Gibt es ja auch den Power-Upload dabei.
Guck mal, hier bezahle ich quasi 70 und dann müsste ich da noch mal den Kabelanschluss dabei rechnen.
Wir rechnen jetzt den Power-Upload dabei.
Da bin ich ja so viel teurer, ist das im Prinzip gar nicht.
Die Frage ist, ist das noch eine statische IPv4?
Das wäre tatsächlich eine Option.
Dann würde ich halt 85 Euro im Monat bezahlen, also im Prinzip nur 5 Euro mehr.
Ich meine, es kostet 20 Euro mehr als das normale, ne?
Ne, 10 Euro, ne, da kommt noch ein Power-Upload dabei.
15, 15 Euro mehr als das normale.
Das sind dann 15 Euro im Monat, ich meine aber an sich ist das tatsächlich eine Überlegung wert, dass ich mir einen Basiskabelanschluss lasse und dann das Business-Unity-Media hole.
Sofern es da Power-Upload gibt, geht es da Power-Upload?
Weil 20 habe ich, Venture will ich 40, jetzt habe ich auch mal einen 40 gewöhnt.
Power-Upload.
Privatkunden.
Tja, da weiß man nicht, ob das da funktioniert.
Da muss man bei Unity-Media anrufen, aber ansonsten wäre das eine Option.
So, also ich wollte dir das slide erklären.
Ja, Power-Upload, das heißt halt bei denen, ich finde es genauso bescheuert, Power-Upload.
Ist ja nicht so, als könnte man das nicht ohne Probleme machen.
Es ist eh ein bisschen lächerlich, dass sich das etabliert hat, dass die Dinger so krass asynchron sind.
Das ging ja teilweise bis irgendwie 410 ab und so.
Da ist ja das, da wird das A in ADSL von Asynchron zu ASI-DSL jetzt 410.
Ja, in der Schweiz. Du kannst doch in Südkorea gucken, in Südkorea haben sie das auch.
So, aber ich wollte erklären, was dir das slide ist.
Also bei Unity-Media haben sie anscheinend nicht genug IPv4-Adressen.
Die Telekom anscheinend schon.
Deswegen müssen sie sich irgendwas einfallen lassen.
Also man muss sich vorstellen, es gibt viele Seiten, die sind mittlerweile über IPv6 erreichbar.
Allerdings, viele Seiten sind auch nicht über IPv6 erreichbar.
Deswegen kann sich das ein Provider nicht leisten, einfach zu sagen,
darauf geschissen, das IPv4-Internet kannst du nicht drauf zugreifen.
Das kannst du vergessen. Den nimmt keiner und vor allem nicht technisch versierte Leute verstehen das nicht.
Die checken das auch nicht. Wie willst du das denen erklären?
Ich übervorstelle irgendwie, was ich...
Irgendeine Oma will Musikanten-Stadl-Seite aufmachen und die ist nicht über IPv6 erreichbar.
Und die geht nicht, dann ruft sie bei Unity-Media an und dann muss der Unity-Media erklären,
dass sie nur IPv6 hat und kein IPv4 und Musikanten-Stadl nur über IPv4 geht.
Das checkt die nicht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Twitter auch nur IPv4-Only ist.
So, zumindest...
Deswegen sehen wir schon mal, Unity-Media kann sich das nicht leisten, IPv4 außen vor zu lassen.
Problem ist allerdings, sie haben nicht...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier mit Light dabei steht.
Das haben sie erst gar nicht hingeschrieben, glaube ich.
Nachdem sie nicht genug IPv4-Adressen zur Verfügung haben, aber die Leute ans IPv4-Internet anbinden müssen,
was ja erstmal ein Widerspruch ist, greifen sie zu einem Trick.
Und dieser Trick nennt sich der Slide mit Carrier-Crate-Nut.
Das bedeutet, DS steht für Dual-Stack.
Dual-Stack heißt normalerweise und die Telekom macht richtigen Dual-Stack.
Dual-Stack bedeutet normalerweise, du kriegst eine IPv4-Adresse und eine IPv6-Adresse.
Und dann machst du eine DNS-Auflösung und guckst, ob der Dienst, wo du drauf zugreifen willst, über IPv4 oder IPv6 erreichbar ist.
Das siehst du anhand der DNS-Antwort.
Und dann gehst du einfach dorthin, wo es dir danach ist.
Beziehungsweise wo da in Windows die Prioritäten liegen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, Windows wird IPv6 bevorzugen, wenn beides zur Verfügung steht.
Geht, überhaupt kein Problem.
Mit richtigen Dual-Stack.
Bei Dual-Stack Lite ist das jetzt anders.
Du bekommst keine IPv4-Adresse mehr.
Du bekommst nur noch eine, also du bekommst keine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse mehr, wie bei der Telekom.
Das heißt, du bekommst nur noch eine IPv6-Adresse und ich vermute mal eine private IPv4-Adresse.
Und das wird getunnelt quasi von dir zu Unity Media.
Es kann auch sein, dass du nur eine IPv6 kriegst.
Weil 6 auf 4 ist kein Problem, 4 auf 6 geht nicht gescheit.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau im Detail, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Zumindest du kriegst keine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse mehr bei Dual-Stack Lite.
Du kriegst quasi nur noch eine öffentliche IPv6-Adresse.
Und dein IPv4-Traffic wird getunnelt über einen IPv6-Tunnel.
Also sprich, so wie das kleine Rotti gerade geschrieben hat.
Dein IPv4-Traffic läuft über eine IPv6-Verbindung zu Unity Media.
Also über einen Tunnel.
Weil der Endpunkt muss ja wissen, was er damit machen muss.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu Carrier Crate NAT.
Nachdem jetzt ja dein IPv4-Traffic über den IPv6-Tunnel bei Unity Media rauskommt,
müssen dir irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass du jetzt weitergeleitet wirst in das IPv4-Internet.
Nachdem sie aber zu wenig IPv4-Adressen haben, das haben wir immer noch nicht gelöst,
aktuell tunneln sie dich nur über IPv6, machen sie Carrier Crate NAT.
Dass da Carrier davor steht ist im Prinzip egal, das ist das gleiche wie NAT daheim.
Das bedeutet, in dem Fall, du teilst dir dann mit mehreren Kunden auf einem Ausgangspunkt
eine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse.
Also sprich, der Weg ist, von dir IPv4-Traffic durch den IPv6-Tunnel zu Unity Media
dort über einen Ausgang genattet, wo mehrere Leute verwenden.
Das sorgt für zig Probleme bei IPv4-Verbindungen.
Sachen wie Xbox-Lobbies funktionieren nicht richtig, kann man nichts richtig dagegen machen.
Du hast auch keine Chance, beispielsweise in Black Ops The Lobby aufzumachen im neuen,
das ist immer noch P2P-House-Ding.
Obwohl, ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile über IPv6-Gescheit funktioniert.
VoIP ist manchmal problematisch, VPN ist problematisch.
Also das ist wirklich die absolute Krücke, das Ding, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Das ist DSLine und Carrier Cranart.
Also das ist die richtige Krücke, dass das funktioniert.
Das heißt, die Option, einen Unity Media Anschluss zu buchen,
einen Unity Media Business Anschluss, da hast du wieder das Problem,
Business hat anscheinend keinen Power-Upload.
Ich will 40 MBit Upload haben.
Ich kann Business nicht schreiben. Wie schreibt man Business?
Das ist so ein Wort, ich schreibe es aus Prinzip immer falsch.
Was schreibt man das? Fast richtig.
Undisputed tatsächlich kann er nicht.
Allerdings wird Unity Media wissen oder aufzeichnen, wie welche Verbindung gelaufen ist bei ihnen.
Aber prinzipiell sieht dein Gegenüber nicht mehr deine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse,
sondern die öffentliche IPv4-Adresse, die bei Unity Media ganz viele Leute verwenden.
Deswegen, übrigens, bekommt man sau oft das Google-Capture.
Kennt ihr das Google-Suche-Capture?
Das kommt immer, wenn man zu viel Suchernfragen verursacht und Google denkt, du bist ein Bot.
Das hast du laufend über Unity Media.
Wenn du es per IPv4 verwendest, hast du das laufend bei Unity Media,
weil die Absender-IP von, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute so einen Ausgang verwenden.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 100.
Ein Vorteil ist dann doch mehr Sicherheit im Netz.
Eigentlich nicht, weil du hast ja bei dir bei IPv4 auch noch mal natt davor.
D.h., du hast doppelt natt.
Also hättest du, wenn du was dazwischen hast, was die ganze Sache noch schlimmer macht.
Und ein riesiger Nachteil davon ist, darf man nicht vergessen,
das liest sich jetzt erst mal so, gut, kann man damit leben, es gehen keine Port-Forwarding.
Weil, ist ja ganz logisch, wenn Port-Forward bedeutet,
von der öffentlichen IP, die auf deinem Router liegt,
oder wie die Cisco Leute gerne sagen, auf deinem Router,
dort sagst du, Port XY wird auf die interne IP eins weitergeleitet.
Das geht ja damit nicht, weil die Verbindungen, die zu dir wollen,
bleiben schon mal im Carrier-Clip-Natt hängen.
Und Unity Media wird mir bestimmt nicht erlauben,
auf ihre Router drauf zu gehen und eine Port-Weiterleitung einzurichten für mich.
Eine Router, genau. Eine Router.
Ja, da stimmt es. Also für die meisten Nutzer, da muss ich TheraFox recht gehen,
für die meisten Nutzer merken das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Leute, die ein bisschen basteln wollen, die quasi VPN heimauf machen wollen,
die irgendwie ihre Nextcloud in der Reverse-Proxy daheim stehen haben,
oder irgendwie sowas, und wo es nicht möglich ist, über IPv6 zuzugreifen,
die werden es merken.
Mittlerweile der Grund, warum ich es damals unbedingt haben wollte,
noch IPv4 für meinen Unity Media Anschluss,
unabhängig von den Problemen, die ich hatte.
Ich überleg grad, was das hauptsächliche Problem war, was nicht funktioniert hat.
Ich hab zumindest Unity Media übelst geflamed auf Twitter, das weiß ich noch.
Gucken wir doch mal, was ich da geschrieben hab.
Da sehen wir auch wieder, was für Probleme ich hatte.
Aber das Problem, also das IPv6 aus dem Mobile-Netzproblem gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich denn geschrieben hab.
Zumindest hatte ich irgendwelche Probleme, was mir...
Hab ich irgendwas an den Lost geschrieben?
Wenn alles so bleibt, bin ich mit der Lösung von Unity Media zufrieden.
So, jetzt nur die Frage, was ich für ein Problem hatte.
Aktuell funktioniert nun alles, super Sache.
Das ist ja schön, Max, dass alles funktioniert.
Aber was war denn das Problem?
Außer, dass ich ohne die Media lobe sehe ich da jetzt nichts.
Ja, ja, die YouTube-Uploads waren am Arsch.
Stimmt, das war mein Problem damals, genau.
YouTube über IPv4, was damals noch nicht richtig über IPv6 funktioniert hat,
war IPv4-Traffic per Kilobyte.
Übelst lahm.
Das war das Problem damals, hab ich gesagt.
Unity Media, ich hab mal euren Anschluss nur geholt,
wenn ihr das Upload als die anderen habt.
Und was ich damit machen will, ist YouTube-Videos hochladen.
Bei euch noch beschissener.
Ja, und da haben sie sich relativ schnell drum gekümmert.
Also schnell ist die Sache, was?
21. Januar hab ich das gepostet.
21. Januar und die Sache gegessen war...
Ah, siehst du, das hat doch eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Das hat doch...
Also die haben auch schon irgendwie drei Wochen oder so gebraucht.
Da hab ich dann immer umgeschaltet, wieder auf die Telekom.
Richtig fail.
So, und das ist halt das Problem gewesen.
Ich denke mal, ich denke mal, das ist mittlerweile behoben.
Wenn nicht, wenn nicht, das wäre halt echt das Problem, ne.
Wenn nicht, brauch ich wieder zwei Anschlüsse parallel.
Und das geht mir halt auf den Sack.
Ich bezahle so viel Geld für Internet-Anschlüsse,
die ich eigentlich gar nicht brauche.
Nur für den Fall der Fälle.
Ja.
Telekom hab ich jetzt für Upload, falls über Unity Media zu langsam ist.
Wenn Telekom rumgespuckt, hab ich Unity Media.
Am liebsten hätt ich nur noch Unity Media.
Da würd ich die Festnetz-Telefonnummern portieren lassen auf Unity Media.
Und nachdem jetzt Telekom im Endeffekt auch nur noch VoIP ist,
ähm, nur noch Unity Media Telekom weg.
Das wär mir eigentlich am liebsten.
Aber sobald du wieder Probleme mit Unity Media hast
oder irgendwas nicht funktioniert und der Upload lahm ist,
da musst du dich wochenlang mit denen rumzackern.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich ist die beste Lösung wirklich
einen Unity Media Business-Anschluss und gucken, ob es Power-Upload gibt.
Unity Media Business mit 40 MBit Upload wäre doch ganz gut.
Dann würd ich halt, dann würd ich immer noch weniger bezahlen,
als jetzt mit zwei Anschlüssen.
Dann würd ich dann irgendwie 85, 89 Euro bezahlen im Monat
für Unity Media Business mit Basiskabelanschluss.
Ja.
Ach, gibt es nicht?
Gibt kein Power-Upload für Unity Media.
Siehste, das macht schon mal wieder Scheiße.
Und was Schlussfolgen wir da raus?
Es gibt einfach keine gute Lösung für Internet in Deutschland.
Das ist so für'n Arsch.
Dass du dir um so viel Scheiße Gedanken machen musst, weißt du?
Richtig reudig alles.
Läuft P2P-File-Sharing also Torrent über Unity Media?
Bestimmt nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Torrent ordentlich über Dual-Stack-Lite läuft.
Genauso wie was gab's früher noch?
E-Dunkey und sowas.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Könntest du nicht VPN benutzen über den Unity Media Anschluss
und dann darüber Port Forwarding machen?
Wenn ich VPN über den Unity Media Anschluss benutze, heißt das ja schon,
ich brabe auf beiden Seiten IPv6.
Wenn ich auf beiden Seiten schon IPv6 hab,
dann brauch ich auch kein Port Weiterleitung mehr,
weil da kann ich direkt drauf zugreifen.
Es besteht die Möglichkeit, sich selbst einen Tunnel zu bauen.
Wenn man einen Server im Internet hat,
kann man selbst einen IPv4 über 6 Tunnel bauen.
Das hab ich damals auch mal kurz gemacht, das war auch nicht gerade schön.
Aber wenn du eh schon IPv6 auf beiden Seiten hast,
brauchst du ja kein Tunnel mehr.
Nextcloud selbst hosten und über VPN zugreifen oder Server anbieten
und darauf Nextcloud hosten in Bezug auf Sicherheit und Machbarkeit bei DSLite.
Ich würd' Nextcloud immer auf einem Server bei mir daheim hosten.
Immer.
Weil da legst du ja privates Zeug drauf.
Das würd' ich nicht irgendwie unverschlüsselnd extern rumliegen lassen.
Oder selbst verschlüsselnd...
Also, ich würd' mein Zeug nicht extern hinstellen,
wenn ich genug Bandbreite daheim hätte.
Und über DSLite zugreifen ist, denke ich mal, in den meisten Fällen heute kein Problem mehr.
Es geht über DSLite zugreifen besser als über...
Also, nein Schwachsinn.
Es geht über IPv6 auf jeden Fall besser als über irgendwelche Nattgeschichten und DSLite.
DSLite, wenn du direkt IPv6 auf beiden Seiten hast.
Ich würd' bloß zwischen Internet und Nextcloud irgendeinen Universproxy stellen.
Der dann noch mal zusätzliche Alternifizierung macht.
Am besten Two-Factor-Authentifizierung und erst danach dich auf die Nextcloud lässt.
Was zahlst du aktuell monatlich?
Ja, ähm, also, muss ich mal überlegen, irgendwie 60... irgendwie 60 Euro Unity Media von was ich...
Was sag ich euch, äh...
Wie viel hat das Telekom-Ding gekostet?
Das da, 5 und...
110 Euro muss ich bezahlen im Monat aktuell.
Deswegen will ich ja auch weg von diesem doppelten Internet-Kack.
Also, Unity Media ist ja schon mehr oder weniger gekündigt.
Allerdings überleg ich jetzt gerade es umgedreht zu machen, Telekom wieder zu kündigen und komplett auf Unity Media zu gehen.
Und dann, wisst ihr was ich dann mach?
Dann leg ich mir einfach als Backup daheim irgendeinen LTE-Stick hin oder so.
Wenn es wirklich mal abkacken gar nicht mehr geht.
Weil ohne Internet kann ich halt nicht leben, das funktioniert nicht.
Dann mach ich, äh...
Mach ich LTE oder so.
Tera Fox, was meinst du, viele Jahrzehnte noch bis in Deutschland mal was ändert?
Na angeblich, angeblich, ja doch bis Ende 2018, ja.
Angeblich bis Ende 2018.
Ich zeig euch das mal.
Hab ich das falsch geschrieben?
Regierungs-Sprecher.
Wo hab ich das denn hier geschrieben, magste Regierungsprecher?
Äh...
Da.
Haben sie doch geschrieben, guck mal.
Haben sie letztes Jahr geschrieben, am 20. Juni haben sie geschrieben,
50 MBit für jeden Haushalt werden wir 2018 schaffen, aber inzwischen müssen wir in Gigabit denken.
Das ist im Prinzip der Regierungsprecher Twitter-Account versucht vielleicht den Rekord zu brechen,
wie viel Scheiße man in 240 Zeichen schreiben kann.
Ansonsten, realistisch gesehen glaube ich nicht, dass wir es in naher Zukunft,
also damit meine ich die nächsten, sagen wir mal 20 Jahre, schaffen werden,
irgendwie internettechnisch aufzuholen an den Rest der Welt, um uns drum herum,
wenn wir, wir können uns glücklich schätzen, wenn wir es schaffen, nicht noch weiter zurückzufallen,
weil ich sehe nicht, dass hier irgendwie Weichen gestellt werden für das Internet in Zukunft.
Andere Länder kriegen das hin.
Südkorea hat glaube ich ungefähr die Hälfte der Einwohner von Deutschland
und ist irgendwie nur, ist irgendwie halb so groß oder ein Drittel so groß oder so,
nur bei denen funktioniert das wunderbar.
Du hast ISDN, das glaube ich dir nicht sehbar.
Und ernsthaft, gibt es für euch nichts anderes?
Das ist ja eigentlich laut dem Regierungsprecher bis Ende 2018 gar nicht möglich.
Was ich auch geil finde, jedes Mal bei der Overwatch League, die Werbung von der Telekom,
America's fastest unlimited network, dann denke ich mir immer,
Alter, ihr Spasten, wenn ihr das mal daheim auch hinkriegen würdet.
Ja, in Dänemark, ich glaube es war in Dänemark, da haben die das gar nicht,
ich bin mir nicht sehr, also nageln mich jetzt nicht drauf fest, ob es Dänemark war,
aber ich glaube es war Dänemark, da hatten die wohl auch Probleme,
es könnte auch ein anderes skandinavisches Land gewesen sein,
da hatten die auch Probleme mit ihren Internetanbietern,
dass sie quasi nicht das gemacht haben, was die Leute wollten
oder nicht so richtig das gemacht haben, was die Regierungen wollten,
wahrscheinlich wollte da die Regierung ausnahmsweise mal das, was auch die Leute wollten
und da haben sie es so gemacht, um da ein bisschen Druck aufzubauen,
haben sie olle Funkmasten gekauft und überall hingestellt
und haben quasi super billig Basic Internet angeboten,
für jeden saumäßig günstig, ich glaube das war es Dänemark gewesen,
sprich, dass jeder ziemlich billig, halt jetzt nicht gerade das beste
und auch über Funk, Internet kriegen konnte
und haben halt so dann die Internetanbieter mehr oder weniger dazu gezwungen,
quasi Besseres anzubieten, weil sie halt nicht konkurrieren konnten
mit den staatlichen Funkmasten, das war halt eine nice Idee,
die mussten dann quasi aufrüsten, weil ansonsten hätte die Oma gesagt,
ja Moment, warum soll ich denn hier bei euch 80 Kronen haben die in Dänemark
oder haben die auch Euro, ach was weiß ich, bezahlen
und wenn ich es hier vom Funkmasten um die Ecke für 25 kriege,
warum soll ich das machen?
Das heißt, die einzigen Verkaufsargumente die noch hatten war,
ihr Zeug besser zu machen oder billiger.
Ja, ja.
Dänische Kronen.
So, eigentlich wollte ich heute noch ein bisschen Progas machen,
aber es ist schon 21.02.
Also im Prinzip ist der Progas das, wo wir stehen geblieben sind das letzte Mal.
Progas animiert ein Papagei mit 25, 26 FPS.
Ich habe das noch ein bisschen geändert hier unten,
ich habe das ein bisschen, kann ich so, ich mache eins kleiner,
so ist okay, so ist zu klein, so ist gut.
Ich glaube so hatten wir es auch nicht, ich glaube so hatten wir es die ganze Zeit.
Ich habe das ein bisschen kleiner gemacht,
ein bisschen einfacher mit dem Timer hier von gestern
und habe hier ein bisschen das Zeug ausgelagert in extra Methoden,
dass das ein bisschen einfacher ist.
Ich habe eingebaut, dass man resizen kann,
was ja gestern noch nicht funktioniert hat, guck, man kann jetzt resizen.
Allerdings, ihr seht schon, das Resize ruckelt.
Das Resize ruckelt, weil ich quasi halt meine Rendersache quasi weighted
und 25 FPS ist halt nur ruckelt halt.
Aber ihr seht schon, aspektmäßig resizen funktioniert auch.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Dieses hässliche Rectangle muss ich auch noch anpassen.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen als erstes jetzt nochmal schnell das Resizen Smoosier,
weil wenn man das Ganze jetzt zum Beispiel mit 12 FPS macht,
wir haben auch andere GIFs, die sind nur 12 FPS,
da ist das Resizen, guckt mal an hier, das ist schon ziemliches Geruckel.
Seht ihr das?
Das Resize halt, die Schleife läuft halt nur 12 Mal in der Sekunde.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt so,
das habe ich mir schon überlegt, das dürfte relativ einfach sein,
wir machen hier kein Sleep drum herum,
wir machen das, also aktuell machen wir es da so, die Billig-Variante,
wir lassen die Schleife einmal durchlaufen und dann warten wir hier
die Zeit bis zum nächsten Frame und dann machen wir wieder den Durchlauf.
Das heißt, wir machen hier im Endeffekt nur ein If draus,
also wir machen die Schleife weg und machen das nächste Frame getten
oder das nächste Frame taken, machen wir einfach hier rein
und dann muss ich glaube ich noch meinen Timer da rein verlagern
und dann sollte das schon funktionieren.
Und das Break muss raus.
Ja guck, jetzt ist super schmooze hier das Resizen.
Super schmoozes Resizen.
Und auch keine Memory Leaks, ja.
Wir können übrigens noch eine Sache machen,
ich will mal was gucken,
ich habe hier das höchste scaling,
das ist das höchste Scaling,
das ist das höchste Scaling, ich habe hier das höchste Scaling und das höchste Scaling,
Ich habe hier das höchste die höchste das höchste scaling
Also was die meiste rechenleistung frisst
Ja sind ein ticken schneller, aber es hält schön grenzen wir machen beste beste scaling options
Ja wir haben nicht nur wir haben nicht nur einfach fps wir haben fps pro sekunde
Ja
Moment mal die diese fps ist hier na
Also dass das das kriegen das wird auch theoretisch eine ganze ecke schneller hinkriegen aber
Also wenn wir den ich glaube wenn wir den
Den decoder ein bisschen mehr images cashen lassen wobei nicht ist eigentlich egal
Ich glaube viel schneller kriegen wir es nicht hin aber es ist ja nicht so als ist es jetzt hier ein problem
Das ist schon okay
Ich sehe auch so ist es wirklich sehr sehr nice schon
Ich meine im prinzip er muss ja auch ein bisschen hier was machen er muss ja mindestens einmal quasi
Also im vergleich zu irgendwelchen games zum wenn man jetzt irgendwelche games hat da kopierst du halt nicht unbedingt
pro pro durchlauf quasi
irgendwelche dinger aus dem ram wieder in die grafikkarte und umgedreht
mein wozu
Dass das hier das dauert wahrscheinlich auch kurz denke ich mal
Und ja hier die tror geschichten werden auch kurz dauern aber ansonsten ist hier halt nix dabei was irgendwie sonderlich lange dauert
Wir könnten das das pausen quasi nur einmal machen wenn wir auch ein bild haben
Bringt ein bisschen was guckt aber nicht viel
Aber nicht viel
Übrigens ist euch aufgefallen ich habe das problem gefixt dass der im debug mod abkackt
Gestern hatten wir noch das problem dass wenn ich die bugger dran hatte dass es abgekackt ist
und
Es sah zwar im stream so aus als haben wir es gefixt aber es war nicht wirklich weg
Wir waren einfach zu langsam als dass wir es gemerkt hätten
Ich habe es gefixt und zwar eben die coder
mache es jetzt so ich
mach das hier mit mit pointer action also
Ich mach kein frame und schreibe den frame in die liste und sonst war es kein frame objekt ich mache nur einen
pointer zu einem frame und schreibe auch nur den
Nur den pointer für den frame quasi in meine frame klasse und dann passt das
Ja gut cpu braucht das ding immer noch ordentlich weil das läuft ja ordentlich das läuft ja krass
Das das ist hier am wir machen jetzt noch mal wie sync an gleich das ist ja komplett komplett am rotieren
Übrigens wir sind auf auf 89 mb runter also 980 mb ist absolut top da kann es keiner beschwerden für
Ist instant da es ist auch schnell
Das ding rödelnt halt hier im hintergrund na wenn man das jetzt zum beispiel sleepen lassen
Wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie noch mal sleepen lassen dann sehen wir auch gleich dass die cpu last halt übel schnell runter geht
Guck jetzt haben wir kaum jetzt haben wir kaum cpu noch gar nichts mehr an cpu aber man ist ja auch klar wir machen ja auch nichts mehr
So wir machen wie sync an ich muss mal gucken wo man sich das anbieten kann
So wir machen wie sync an ich muss mal gucken wo man das macht wahrscheinlich den swapchain options
Ach übrigens wir müssen die back noch mal ausschalten die back auf dem xd device da geht es noch ein ticken schneller
Ja guckt mal hier
Guck mal ich wollte gerade sagen warum ist es so langsam
Guck mal
4500 fps für den papagei
Und ein bisschen ein bisschen scale müssen wir noch dass das ich hätte am liebsten dass das quasi in die mitte scale wenn ich das fenster so
so scale ist ja
Jetzt noch release ich ich memory liege nix das sieht nur so aus guck mal
Der macht einfach nur seinen cache voll
Das bleibt jetzt das geht das geht nicht nicht nicht mal wirklich hoch
Also da muss man sich schon sehr anstrengen dass jetzt irgendwie hoch geht also da liegt nix
Das ist eigentlich die ressourcen der muss da alles selbst machen und wie das auf der grafik läuft keine ahnung wie macht man denn
Wie macht man da wie sync an? Bei einem reinen direct 2d device wüsste ich wie das geht? Da müssen wir mal google befragen würde ich sagen
Present interval
Wir müssen mal mal Google befragen, würde ich sagen.
Present Interval.
Wir müssen mal, wir müssen 11 suchen. Wir machen das ja, wir sind ja, wir sind ja modern.
Ja Noah, gehe ich sofort aus.
Ja, wie man das, wie man wie so ein Disable ist auch okay, da kann man gucken, so machen wir das umgedrehte.
Dann enablen wir das einfach, der Typ dafür zeugt.
Ich hätte das eigentlich erwartet, dass man das irgendwie in der Swap-Chain als Options angibt.
Aber hier haben wir alle Options drin. Ah Flex, gibt es da vielleicht was?
Ah, da gibt es bestimmt irgendwas.
Nö, gibt es nicht.
Wo? Aber da kann ich gerade nichts anfangen.
Allow Tearing ist doch das Gegenteil von, von wie so, ja quasi, ist da was dran.
Kann man hier vielleicht irgendwas Swap-Effekt?
In der Swap-Chain-Description?
Buffer-Description, sowas habe ich hier doch gar nicht.
Ich habe Buffer-Count?
Also ich habe hier keine Option, ich habe hier alles gesetzt, ich kann bloß auf Flex setzen.
Oder aber muss ich Swap-Chain-Description?
Buffer-Count?
Nö.
Ja, das ist Swap-Chain, aber ich kann ja wahrscheinlich hier auf Description 1 zugreifen, oder?
Geht das nicht? Muss man mal ausprobieren.
So, und da drinne ist es jetzt was?
Swap-Effekt? Nö.
Usage?
Buffer-Count?
Ah, in der, im Present. Das kann natürlich sein, dass wir es im Present machen müssen für, für, für wie so, ja.
Auf was stellen wir es jetzt?
Allow Tearing.
Oh, das funktioniert nicht. Dann kackt es ab.
Was muss man es denn hier stellen? Do not wait ist ja wahrscheinlich das, was wir jetzt haben.
Außer dass es, äh, rippt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was man das aufstellen muss, äh.
Einfach die 0 zu 1.
Ich muss da den Enum reinhauen. Was ist denn, was ist denn hier die 1 drinne?
Ich meine, ich kann, ich kann das casten. Ah ja, Test.
Test?
Hatshaft.
Nö.
Loll.
Ach, der erste Parameter.
Sync Inter, sag das doch.
Ah, ein nicer V-Sync.
Guck mal, wir sind sogar besser als mein V-Sync. Wir sind sogar, anstatt 144, sind wir 145.
Aber auch nur manchmal.
Der erste Parameter, jaja, ich habs, ich habs jetzt gesehen.
Was hast du für eine Visual Studio Version?
Die neueste.
I think so.
1588, es gibt jetzt eine neue, es gibt, es gibt, äh, übrigens schon Pläne für, habe ich letztens gelesen.
2019, gibt es jetzt, sollte auch irgendwo ein Preview dazu kommen demnächst.
Und was mich übelst geschockt hat, ist, was ich gesehen hab,
was Microsoft angekündigt hat, ist
Office 2019. Ich hab gedacht, wir sind's endlich los, ja.
Die lassen jetzt für immer ihr 360-Gramm und man hat seine Ruhe mit, aber nein, es gibt wieder eine neue Offline-Office-Version.
Dass wieder, wieder viele Leute, viele graue Haare bringen, ja.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich benutze ja schon seit Jahren kein Office mehr.
Ich brauch für nichts Office.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn, ähm, sag mal so der normale User für irgendwie seinen Zeug ein bisschen Office braucht.
Ich, ich bin der Ansicht von Office, das einzig, das einzige, ähm,
was Office wirklich, wie soll ich sagen, also,
das einzige Office-Programm, was seine Daseinsberechtigung hat, ist meiner Ansicht nach Excel.
Ja, also wie viele Hobby-Anwendungen quasi in Excel programmiert sind, will ich gar nichts wissen.
Ähm.
Aber ansonsten, die ganzen anderen Krämpel, was ist denn, was ist denn eigentlich so ein Office dabei?
Zeig mal hier, was, was ist denn da starrmäßig dabei?
Was gibt's denn da alles so?
All things done mit Office, mit, mit Office nix done.
Was haben wir denn da so alles drinne?
Zeig mal her.
Die schreiben doch nicht mal hin, was es gibt, oder?
Ich will doch einfach nur wissen, ah, okay.
Word, Excel, PowerPoint, OneNote, Outlook.
Okay, also, Word ist die unsinnigste Anwendung aller Zeiten.
Das ist bloß was für Leute, die nichts halbes und nichts ganzes suchen, ja.
Also wenn ich einfach was zum Schrei-, wenn ich einfach nur was schreiben will und leserlich formatieren,
dann mach ich das mit einem Text-Editor in Markdown.
Und wenn ich, ähm, kompliziertes Layout machen will, dann mach ich das mit irgendeinem Layout-Programm oder Latex.
Latex.
Word ist halt nur für die Oma gut, die mal Geburtstagseinladung machen will.
Need help, yes?
Thank you for contacting Microsoft, Agent.
Moment.
Der ist ja wirklich am Start.
Piss dich, Alter. Geh weg.
Lul.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gedacht, das ist eher so ein Fake-Chat.
Also, Word, komplett sinnlos, braucht man nicht.
Powerpoint auch komplett sinnlos, braucht man nicht.
Das brauchen nur irgendwelche Leute, irgendwelche Business-Leute, die Powerpoint-Präsentation machen wollen.
Es gibt genug andere Möglichkeiten, gute Präsentation zu machen und Powerpoint.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch zig Markdown-Präsentation-Tools.
Oder ansonsten, wisst ihr was ich persönlich auch mag?
Einfach PDF.
Weil ich mein, es geht, die ganzen Sachen, die du in Powerpoint machen kannst,
teiten dich ja in der Regel eigentlich nur von der Präsentation ab.
Also du brauchst nichts, was großartig einfadet an Schrift oder sonst was.
Ich mag einfach entweder die Sachen, die Sachen auch in Markdown machen,
oder eben halt einfach als PDF.
Da machst du einen PDF-Reader in Fullscreen, machst einfach Seite weiter, Seite zurück.
Also ob, kein Ding.
Powerpoint hab ich, glaub ich, gefühlt seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr oft gehabt.
Und OneNote ist ganz okay.
Da sieht man schon mal, wie verzweifelt die sind, dass das mittlerweile in Office dabei ist.
Früher hatten sie noch diesen Bullshit wie Access und sowas.
Das gibt's ja, gibt's anscheinend gar nicht mehr, so wie es aussieht.
Oder gibt's das noch?
Oh je.
Wir bleiben ja auch vor nichts verschont.
Wir bleiben ja auch echt vor nichts verschont.
Da gibt's Publisher.
Das ist, oh, das ist Brechreiz, Publisher.
Das ist auch so eine Software, wo ich nicht weiß, wozu man die braucht.
Liest ihr den Chat überhaupt?
Ich lese eigentlich die ganze Zeit den Chat.
Und Access braucht eigentlich auch kein Mensch.
Hat sich eher nach Kacken angehört.
Kannste dir aussuchen.
Was soll denn Publisher sein?
Ich glaube, das ist dieser Versuch von Microsoft, so einen Layout-Programm zu machen.
Es ist kacke.
Ich hab's vor Jahren irgendwann mal für irgendwas verwendet.
Ja, guck, es ist so ein Layout-Programm von Microsoft.
Es ist wirklich, ich weiß gar nicht, wofür man das überhaupt verwenden sollte, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist quasi für die Leute, die aus Word rausgelevelt sind oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wozu.
Also, für den Arsch, für den Arsch, für den Arsch, für den Arsch.
Bleiben noch zwei Sachen übrig, Excel und Outlook.
Outlook prinzipiell auch für den Arsch, es sei denn, man steht auf Exchange und möchte den ganzen Scheiß drumherum verwenden.
Also von Terminen bis zu Mobile-Clients und Gedöns dann vielleicht.
Ansonsten, das einzige Programm, was irgendwie eine Daseinsberechtigung hat, ist Excel.
Und selbst das braucht man eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Und das hier schreckt mich, also das hier enthaltene Dienstes Skype erschreckt mich ja noch mehr ab.
Wir debaten Microsoft jetzt.
Achtung, wir warten jetzt, bis der Kontakt was schreibt.
Mit Kyle, mit Kyle chatten wir und Bam.
Debated Kyle.
Mal gucken, wie oft wir Kyle anschreiben können.
Ja.
Oh, da ist Kyle ja wieder.
Oh, Kyle ist hartnäckig.
Ich will Kyle nicht mehr.
Oh, es ist Kyle.
Okay, der geht nicht mehr weg.
Ich mach den Browser lieber zu, wer weiß was noch hier passiert.
Das ist ein Bot, klar ist es ein Bot.
Das ist genauso wie die ganzen Calls an der Mitarbeiterin, was laut Bildern immer hübsche Frauen sind.
Immer, wenn du auf irgendeiner Internetseite Support-Hotline siehst, dann sind da immer, immer, immer Bilder von irgendwelchen hübschen Mädels.
Support-Hotline, du weißt halt, ich hab vor Jahren mal einen Artikel gelesen, wie man sowas nennt.
Der hat das Happy Talk genannt, nach dem Motto, weil es immer halt ultra glücklich auf Werbefotos.
Das sind keine jungen hübschen Mädchen, ja.
Vielleicht sind das auch alte Mädels, ja kann ja auch sein.
Aber ich vermute mal, hier zum größten, da sind gar keine Mädels bei der Hotline.
Also zumindest nicht zu 95% wie das die Bilder einem weismachen wollen.
Am besten ist hier immer noch indischer Support.
Hallo, mein Name ist Peter, weil der Inder auch Peter heißt.
Nicht Peter.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir haben nur eine halbe Stunde Zeit für Progas.
Ich meine, das sieht immer noch ziemlich absichtlich aus, aber wir haben Vsync an.
Wir gucken jetzt mal unsere CPU-Last an.
Guck mal, wir brauchen keine CPU mehr.
Vsync regelt.
Aja ja.
Warum ich genau den Rahmen gerade eingeblendet habe, weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich stelle den Rahmen mal wieder aus.
Ah, da habe ich übrigens schon mal meinen Nicen Hack gezeigt.
Und zwar das Problem ist, dass standardmäßig die...
Also ich muss euch das nochmal zeigen.
Das ist ja unter Windows mal wieder nicht so einfach, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Also das Fenster hier hat ja einen Rahmen, das ganz dünn.
Ich würde mal sagen so 1-2 Pixel oder sowas.
Einen Rahmen und eine Titelleiste.
Und ihr seht schon, ich habe hier so ein bisschen Offset von meinem Rahmen, den ich gemalt habe.
Das liegt daran, dass selbst wenn ich den Rahmen, wenn ich das Fenster transparent mache,
dass der Rahmen zwar nicht mehr da ist, aber abgezogen wird von meiner Klein Area, wo ich drinnen selber malen kann.
Und das bedeutet, dass ich alles mit einem Offset von 20 Pixel links und 40 Pixel oben malen muss.
Oben, weil Titelleiste halt größer ist.
So, und deswegen habe ich das so gemacht.
Das ist richtig nice hier.
Ich suche mir quasi raus die Koordinaten zur Monitor, relativ zur Monitor gesehen,
von meinem Fenster, äußere Ecken und dann ziehe ich davon ab,
oben Abstand zu Bildschirm, minus Abstand von meinem inneren kleinen Bereich.
Und dann kriege ich raus, wie viel weiter oben ich anfangen muss, nach unten zu malen
und wie viel weiter von links nach rechts ich anfangen zu malen muss,
dass ich quasi beim ersten Pixel lande, den man sehen kann.
Und dann setze ich eine Transform Matrix, das ist auch etwas für alle,
die ein bisschen Free-Framework-Geschichten benutzen oder ein bisschen 3D-Kram machen.
Das kommt dann relativ oft, dass man sowas braucht.
Und ich sage hier einfach Translation, also sprich,
alle Aktionen, die ich hier mit meinem Painter, also da, wo ich dann letztendlich die Bilder male,
alle Aktionen, die ich ausführe und Koordinaten dabei angebe,
was ich im Endeffekt bei ganz vielen Sachen tue, die sind automatisch schon verschoben um diesen Offset.
Das heißt, Koordinate 0,0 ist logisch gesehen für meinen Painter 0,0.
Auf dem Hintergrund ist es allerdings wirklich Offset Y und Offset X.
Ich hoffe, man hat das jetzt verstanden.
Window-Style-VS-Pop, aber das kann ich mal ausprobieren.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ne, Moment.
Welche Programmiersprache ist das? Das ist die Sharp.
Das Web-Frontend ist in Vue.js und das Server-Backend ist ASP.NET Core.
Gucken wir mal, was passiert, wenn wir das so setzen.
Ach, come on, Microsoft.
WinForms ist zu alt.
Das erlaubt als Parameter, das nicht zu setzen.
Ist das euer Ernst jetzt oder was?
Und Cast nach Int kann ich nicht, weil es zu groß ist.
Aber ich kann bestimmt hier drin das setzen.
Border, Border-Style.
Tool-Window oder irgendwie sowas.
Gucken wir mal meinen Offset, ob ich den jetzt noch brauche.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Hinweis, dass das eine bessere Idee ist.
Ne, ist immer noch das gleiche, 31.8.
Was kann ich da denn noch für Dinger hinschreiben?
31.8. Ändert sich überhaupt nicht.
Tja.
Nun, jetzt sollte sich auch was dran ändern.
Ja, jetzt ist es 0.0.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Jetzt ist es 0.0.
Ja, das war auch gut.
So kann man das auch machen.
Oder ich mache meinen Offset-Gestellte, das geht natürlich auch.
Ne, das L ist das, das der richtige Typ ist.
Warum heißt der Painter immer noch nicht Bob Ross?
Das ist eigentlich eine geile Idee.
Das ist eigentlich eine lustige Idee.
Also, die richtige Bezeichnung ist, glaube ich, Kontext.
Aber bei Cute heißt das immer Painter.
Aber Bob Ross finde ich auch nice.
Jetzt malt Bob Ross.
Jetzt wird es von Bob Ross gedraht.
Und da Buchhalter konnte der indische Support helfen.
Skype habe ich selbst verwendet.
Ja, das stimmt.
Skype war ja auch mal eine Zeit lang gar nicht so kacke.
Aber mittlerweile ist Skype ganz, ganz räudig geworden.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man so verkacken kann.
Aber man muss auch sagen, Discord ist halt für das meiste echt die bessere Alternative.
Discord ist die einzige Node.js-Elektron-Chromium-Gedöns-Anwendung, die ich gerne verwende.
Und das wahrscheinlich auch nur, weil sie performance-kritische Sachen als Node.js-C-Plugin dabei haben.
Slack ist okay.
Aber Slack ist auch so ein Electron Node.js-Geschwobbel.
Was ich gar nicht so genau verstehe, ist, warum sich Slack eigentlich durchgesetzt hat.
Ich meine, in den Chat konnte man sich mit Jammer seit Jahren schon, oder nur wohl mit IRC,
konnte man sich da einen ordentlichen Chatraum aufmachen und labern.
Ich weiß, bei Slack gibt es ja noch irgendwelche Bots, da kannst du da quasi schreiben deploy XY
und dann macht er das.
Aber das konntest du prinzipiell auch schon in jedem anderen Chatraum machen.
Ansonsten weiß ich nicht, was ist der Vorteil von Slack gegenüber einem Jabber-Chatraum?
Außer, dass der Kleinen schöner aussieht.
Was jetzt aber nicht unbedingt so sehr für Slack spricht,
eher für das Verkacken der Leute, die ordentliche Java-Klines programmiert haben.
So, was machen wir jetzt?
Es war noch irgendwas Kleines hier.
Viel müssen wir eh nicht mehr machen.
Das Resizing muss man auch richtig hinkriegen.
Komische Geräusche im Skype.
Das Video kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Ich würde gerne irgendwie das Bild scalen lassen.
Das Bild scalet ja, aber ich würde es gerne in die Mitte scalen lassen.
Wobei eigentlich braucht man das nicht.
Das ist eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Wie macht man eigentlich ordentliches Drag und Drop jetzt mit Windows Forms nochmal?
Das habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht.
Mal kurz gucken.
Was?
Da brauche ich kein Interop für, um eine borderless Form zu moveen.
Schwachsinn.
Was ist mit denen los, ey?
Ich kann doch garantiert...
Ich meine, die einfachste Variante wäre, wenn ich sage...
Da gibt es aber bestimmt eine schönere Variante.
Dann mache ich einfach bis Maus ab, folge meinem Maus-Zeiger.
Das wäre die billigste Variante, aber das geht bestimmt schöner.
Was gibt es denn für Track-Events?
On-Track-Drop, On-Track-Enter, On-Track-Leave.
Ich habe es schon gesehen, ich habe bloß Chat nicht gerade so genau angeguckt.
TCP Port-Sharing-Error, der nur bei wenigen Kunden auftritt.
WCF, das ist aber überhaupt das Richtige.
Ist WCF nicht diese XML-Communication-Gedöns?
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Das ist eklig zu verwenden.
Ja, doch, ich glaube, das ist dieses XML-Zeug, dieses uralte XML-Communication-Dings.
Das habe ich schon damals nicht genau gecheckt, wofür man es verwendet.
Und heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr verwenden will.
Ich bin nur wegen den Microsoft-Trolls hier.
Wir haben ja nichts gemacht, wir haben den Chat ein paar Mal zugemacht.
Wie move ich denn ordentlich ein Windows-Forms-Window?
Gibt es doch bestimmt eine schöne Lösung, dass wir das nicht komplett von Hand bauen müssen.
Die machen ernsthaft, das ist doch...
Hey, was ist denn das?
Warum machen die das alles mit irgendwie...
Das geht doch bestimmt schöner.
Kennt hier jemand eine schöne Möglichkeit,
in einer WPF-Anwendung Bilder von einem externen USB-Gerät zum Handy zu importieren?
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es eine Library gibt für exakt diesen Zweck.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du musst ein paar Sachen verbinden.
Ich kann den Scheiß wirklich von Hand machen, oder?
Man konnte doch irgendwie...
Ich muss mal probieren, ob ich das Fenster move-en kann.
Ja, 800.
So, jetzt sollte sich das ja eigentlich bewegen, das Fenster, wenn ich reinklicke.
Das macht es auch, ja easy, dann ist das doch überhaupt kein Ding.
Dann machen wir irgendwie sowas wie...
Das geht bestimmt schöner.
So, und jetzt move-en wir das Fenster einfach...
Einfach mit der Maus.
Aber das geht bestimmt schöner.
Maus move.
Aber das kann doch nicht sein, dass man das wirklich so komplett von Hand track-and-drop basteln muss.
Was, Registry?
Was?
Was los, Chat?
Registry?
Geht mal fort.
Ach, die Windows-Registry, sowas.
Registry ist tatsächlich sowas von MonkaS.
Am besten finde ich ja die Gerüchte um die Registry, ne?
So nach dem Motto, du musst deine Registry defragmentieren und sowas.
Was das überhaupt sein soll, keine Ahnung, kann dir keiner sagen.
Oder, du musst deine Registry cleanen lassen.
Oder, du musst dein Windows neu installieren, weil die Registry voll müllt.
Allerblödsinn, ey.
Am besten sind diese Hacks, diese Tricks, so nach dem Motto, setze diesen Key in der Registry,
der angeblich, wenn du nachguckst, seit Windows 98 in dem Mal ausgelesen wird, ja?
Registry ist echt so ein Mysterium.
Ja, da gebe ich dir recht, Mary, allerdings ist es vieles unter Windows.
Übelste Magie.
Ich mein, guck dir mal das hier an.
Ich hab die Methode extra schon SetupWindowsMagic genannt, ja?
Also, wenn du mir das mal irgendwann erklären kannst, was es macht,
dass es funktioniert, weiß ich dann.
Da würde ich mich freuen.
So, mouseEventArgs.
X, wir machen das jetzt mal ganz, ganz simpel.
This, X, left.
Also, von der Idee her müsste doch jetzt das Ding rufen.
Ach so, if, dragging.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das Deckoverflow irgendwas erzählt.
Es geht über der Maus.
Ah, ich weiß, woran es liegt.
Ja, geh weg.
Ich sollte mit meiner Maus auch im Fenster bleiben.
15 Minuten bis 22 Uhr, ja, leider, leider, leider.
Ich will ja im Fenster bleiben.
Hier plus 20 oder so.
Oder auch nicht.
Irgendwas, irgendwas verkacke ich gerade von der Logik, ja.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Aber ich meine, das Fenster bewegt sich, das passt.
Ich muss 20 abziehen.
Ja, ich musste es erstmal in Screen Coordinates umreichen oder sowas.
Ah, ne, hier Location haben wir doch.
Offset.
Ach, ne, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Das spackt rum, weil das Fenster springt dahin und dann ist das nächste Maus Move Event am Start.
Das wird so ein bisschen anders, aber prinzipiell funktioniert das doch so.
Warum sollte ich da irgendwelche Windows API Geschichten basteln?
Ja, das müsste ich...
Terra Fox muss ich mir nochmal überlegen, aber im Prinzip müsste das doch so funktionieren.
Dass das einfach Fenster dahinspringt, wo die Maus ist.
Deswegen jumpt es auch so hin und her.
Weil das Event an ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Stellen ankommt, aber...
Ich müsste jetzt quasi gucken, wo ist die Maus in Screen Coordinates oder sowas.
Ich müsste jetzt irgendwie sowas gucken.
Irgendwie so, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie translate man Points nochmal.
Point to Client, genau.
Point to Client, Location.
Äh, das ist nicht so ganz richtig.
What?
Moment, das ist schon die Location zum Client.
Das ist gar nicht die Location zum Screen, oder?
Ja, das ist schon die Idee.
Das heißt, ich muss es umgedreht machen.
Ich muss Point to Screen machen.
Mal erstmal so mal probieren.
Ja, guckt. Geht doch.
On, Maus.
Aber da kriege ich hier keine Intelligenz nach.
Maus Capture, ja, das sollten wir machen.
Maus ab.
Also das ist jetzt nur die ganz billige, schnelle Variante, wie man ein ordentliches Dragon Drop von der Form machen kann.
Ja, funktioniert doch prinzipiell.
Das ganze können wir jetzt mal nach oben und unten machen.
Wir müssen uns unsere Screen-Koordinanz merken, wo wir sind.
Also wir müssen das abziehen davon, wir wollen ja nicht immer an den linken Rand springen zum Dragon Dropen vom Fenster.
Aber warum die auf Stackoverflow irgendwas erzählt hätten von, man muss da mit Native-Windows-Täuschen romantieren, weiß ich nicht.
Ach so, die Maus sollten wir noch Capture, ja, das sollten wir machen.
Capture, Maus.
Capture, True.
Okay, das Capture die Maus gar nicht.
Informs, Capture, Maus, wie geht das?
Englisch.
Also mit Capture, Maus meine ich eigentlich, dass die Maus dann verschwindet.
Wobei, das macht Windows ja anscheinend nicht.
Scheint ist Windows, Capture die Maus ja gar nicht.
Kann ich davon jetzt irgendwie X abziehen oder ergibt das keinen Sinn?
Oh, woho.
Okay, nee, das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, was ich da mache.
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich, ach nee, Moment, ich muss davon.
Ich, wir sind jetzt, wir sind jetzt an der linken, wir sind jetzt hier an der linken,
wir setzen das Fenster jetzt auf die linke Ecke.
Von der Clickposition.
Das wollen wir ja gar nicht.
Wir wollen es nicht auf die Clickposition setzen, sondern wir wollen es quasi
links daneben setzen.
Und zwar so viel Pixel, wie der Mauszeiger vom Bildschirmrand, falsche Richtung,
so viel wie der Mauszeiger von der Mitte entfernt ist.
Also quasi Minus.
Also die.
Also davon eigentlich abziehen.
Ah, 363, wieso, das passt doch, aber die nächsten Moves passt nicht mehr.
Das war doch eigentlich, eigentlich war das doch gar nicht so verkehrt,
was ich da gemacht habe, weil von der Logik her in X, in X steht doch,
also in X steht doch, wie weit ich entfernt bin vom linken Rand von meinem Fenster,
oder?
Aber das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist, warte mal, ich glaube, ich muss das, muss ich das hier noch translateen
noch mal?
Nee, hä? Ah, da muss ich mir mal in Ruhe Gedanken kommen, es ist leider schon 22 Uhr.
Aber wir könnten, wir könnten eine Sache noch machen.
Wir könnten hier mal gucken, was passiert, wenn wir Location setzen auf Target.
Dann kannst du zumindest die Y-Achse auch noch mitmachen.
Jopp.
Genau.
Zwar nur die linke obere Ecke.
Aber es funktioniert schon mal.
Oh, man darf da, wollte ich schon sagen, man darf da wohl bestimmt nicht einfach abziehen.
Ja, das funktioniert doch prinzipiell.
Warum, warum genau geht jetzt E-Location nicht, geht das nicht?
Hä?
Moment, ob so eins funktioniert?
Naja, probier ich da noch ein bisschen rum.
Ich muss jetzt leider pennen.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwas überlesen hab noch im Chat.
Von daher würde ich sagen, das ist eigentlich sinnvoll.
Ich mein, das wird nicht funktionieren, das ist...
Aber das andere, man muss mal nachschauen, wie man das ordentlich machen.
Aber ich bin da echt jetzt langsam zufrieden mit.
Wenn wir das jetzt noch hinkriegen, das wäre einfach schön, dass wir schön resizen können.
Das wäre schön, das ist kein großartiges Ding.
Also wir haben dann später keinen Fensterrahmen mehr drum, wir haben nur unseren eigenen Rahmen.
Dass wir hin und her schieben können, was wir teilweise schon können.
Dass wir ordentlich resizen können.
Dann haben wir quasi die Funktion, die das VPF Fenster hatte, nachgebaut.
Was wir dann noch machen müssen, das können wir uns überlegen, ob wir normale Bilder auch mit FFmpeg anzeigen.
Oder ob ich einfach ein... jetzt irgendwie anders noch reinbaue.
Aber ich mein, guck mal, wie simpel es war, im Endeffekt einen GIF zu animieren mit FFmpeg.
Da können wir einen PNG auch ohne Probleme anzeigen lassen.
Da müssen wir halt noch im Zweifelsfall Pixel konvertieren lassen in BGA-Format.
So, habe ich noch irgendwas übersehen?
Hey Max, magst du vielleicht mal über meine PC-Zusammensstellung gucken?
Bist du noch da? Das könnten wir jetzt eigentlich abschließend machen.
Ich muss aber gleich dazu sagen, ich bin ja nicht so extrem auf dem Laufenden.
Aber schick mal, können wir uns angucken, wenn du willst?
Stimmt, richtig, Joke Gaming hat Recht.
Wir müssen das nicht jedes Mal machen, wir müssen uns den Initialen...
Wir müssen uns merken, die Koordinaten, wo wir angefangen haben, zu klicken.
Weil danach stimmt es ja nicht mehr vom nächsten Event.
Und da müssen wir das dann einfach dazu rechnen.
Ja, das geht glaube ich ganz gut.
So, ich glaube jetzt habe ich nichts mehr übersehen.
Ah, da, Rechner-Zusammensstellung, das können wir jetzt aber machen.
Komm, wir gucken uns noch mal kurz die Rechner-Zusammensstellung von Flamehaze an.
Ich vermute mal, dass es nicht Flamehatze ist.
Das ist Haze wieder, das ist quasi der Haze zum Faceclan.
Das ist quasi die deutschsprachige Faceclan-Konkurrenz.
Irgendwie geht der Link nicht, der Link ist falsch.
Das muss bestimmt Lulz heißen hinten, oder?
Nein, muss es auch nicht.
Schick noch mal.
Vielleicht ist deine List auch nicht öffentlich.
Ich gehe davon aus, die Liste ist nicht geshared.
Sebaro, kennste das schon?
Ach du Scheiße!
Der Sebaro schickt uns Weep-Kram.
What the fuck?
Ja, das kenne ich schon.
Ich kenne auch das Video davon, wo das irgendein Typ sich 10 Stunden anschaut.
Das ist ganz verrückt.
Der ist kurz vorm verrecken, der Typ, danach.
Jetzt stimmt es, okay.
Moment.
Ja.
Also, ein neuer PC für den Flamehaze.
Was ist das denn insgesamt?
Das steht nicht dabei.
Das möchte Amazon wahrscheinlich nicht, dass man das sieht.
Okay, also.
Also, wenn du eine kompetente Auskunft haben willst,
würde ich noch mal da in irgendeinem forumfreien Computerbase oder so,
oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, bei hardwarerad oder so,
weiß nicht, irgendwo ein, dass ich damit auskomme.
Aber gucken wir uns mal an.
Also, die SSD ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, die gleiche habe ich auch bloß in der M2-Variante.
Da machst du nicht allzu viel verkehrt.
Ähm, Moment.
Warum denn zweimal?
Was hältst du denn davon?
Was hältst du denn davon, die M2 SSD wegzulassen
und dir eine größere SATA SSD zu holen für den gleichen Preis?
Was sagst du denn dazu?
Kohle gespart?
Sparst du quasi 80 Euro?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du hast zwei, weil dir die M2 zu klein ist, ne?
Und die, und die 1TB zu teuer.
Also hier würde ich die, ach so Volster auch schon, okay.
Ja, also hier würde ich auf jeden Fall die, die 1TB nehmen.
Ich habe ja vor Jahren mal in den sauren Apfel gebissen, ne,
als SSDs noch teuer waren.
Also, ja, ja doch, ist wirklich schon Jahre her.
Ähm, und habe mir eine 2TB damals gekauft
und die hat damals, glaube ich, 600 Euro gekostet oder so.
2TB SSD.
Ich muss gerade mal, ich gucke gerade mal auf den zweiten Rechner nach,
wie teuer der Krams war.
Und, dass ich mal gucke, gucken, wie sehr sich das vergünstigt hat.
SSD, SSD, Samsung, 2TB, ja hier.
2015 habe ich mir die gekauft, 2TB.
Alter, 689 Euro habe ich damals für bezahlt.
Die sogar noch mehr.
700, 700 Euro habe ich bezahlt für die SSD damals.
Krasser Scheiß, ja.
Und jetzt kostet sie, jetzt kostet sie die Hälfte.
Das war der Vorgänger von der.
Was, Postleitzahl liegt?
Wo ist, wo ist eine Postleitzahl geleakt?
Ach, da, haha, ne, stimmt nicht, ganz ist aber in der Nähe.
Man hat es doch schon mal gesehen, dass, dass, dass, dass es in Meintal ist.
Ist doch schon geleakt.
Und wenn ihr wisst, wo der Bahnhof in Meintal ist, ist es auch nicht so weit weg.
So.
Be quiet, die Dinger sind immer ganz gut.
750 Watt, weiß ich nicht, ob du das brauchst.
Das könnte natürlich überdimensioniert sein, kommt auf den Rest an.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das habe ich auch.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch drinne oder kann das sein?
Nee, nicht der, der auch nicht.
Da, wenn man zweimal Rechner sucht, findet man es, okay.
So, warte, hatte ich nicht das gleiche Netzteil drinne?
Doch, aber ich habe die 650 Variante.
Das heißt, du bist wahrscheinlich auch keine 750 brauchen.
So, gucken wir mal, was da sonst noch drinne ist.
Gut, Gehäuse halt, wie es einem gefällt.
Ja, so Rockstricks.
Dazu kann ich nicht wirklich was sagen.
Es ist ein Board für ein AMD Chip, so viel erkenne ich.
Boards kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Das liegt einfach daran, ich weiß nicht, auf was man da aktuell gucken muss.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall abgedreht aus.
Was sind denn die Vorteile von dem Board?
Was haben die denn hier so schönes zu bieten?
Was haben sie denn da so drauf?
Was zeichnet das dann aus?
Gaming, Audio und das Zeug bauen wir einen Einschnitt.
Was?
Jetzt fangen wir schon an mit M2 Lüfter, oder was?
Das wird ja bloß noch vom Asus Monitor getoppt, der einen Lüfter eingebaut hat.
Ja, okay, Mainboard kann ich nicht sagen, aber so lange die CPU passt, okay.
Vielleicht gibt es da günstigere Alternativen, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Da hast du gut was vor.
Alter, da hast du echt aber was vor, ich meine hier.
Preis-Leistung ist das natürlich nicht der Wahnsinn, aber haut rein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon eine ganze Weile die 1080 Ti drinnen.
Übrigens Nvidia, ich mache jetzt auch demnächst wieder mehr Videos.
Ihr könnt mir ruhig noch eine Grafikkarte schicken wieder.
Nur mal so angemerkt, falls das irgendwie einer, nehme ich gerne.
Mach auch was dafür, so ist es nicht.
Und wenn man davon ausgeht, die 280 Ti ist was weiß ich,
irgendwie mal wieder so die üblichen 25% schneller oder so,
dann ist das Ding auf jeden Fall ordentlich Wumms.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, die Preise von Grafikkarten
sind mittlerweile echt jenseits von Gut und Böse.
Früher hast du für Highend 800 Euro bezahlt.
Also Nvidia nutzt da schon gnadenlos aus,
dass AMD im absoluten Highend-Segment nichts zu bieten hat.
Und als CPU sieht man ja auch, dass es was bringt,
wenn da noch ein zweiter mit am Start ist.
Nvidia kannst du halt hier aktuell machen, wie sie lustig sind.
Und 1500 Euro für das Highend-Modell ist eigentlich ein schlechter Witz.
Wenn du dir überlegst, für den Preis hast du früher die Titan-Grafen,
hast du dir früher die Titan geholt.
Das ist ja noch mal eins drüber.
Und jetzt kostet das normale Highend-Modell 1500 Euro.
Das ist schon, also, weiß nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall bestimmt eine nice Grafikkarte.
Corsair Vengeance-Dings.
2x16G.
Boah, da kann man bestimmt nicht viel falsch sprechen mit.
Du musst ja mal gucken, dass sie unter Lüfter passen
bei diesen komischen Kühlrippen-Rams.
Was ist die Blue von MD?
War das nicht für Videoüberwachung?
Kann man machen.
Da musst du wissen, wie viele du da brauchst.
So, und jetzt kommt natürlich die Preinfalle.
Den Rützen.
2700XL.
Das Ding ist auf jeden Fall nice, wenn man sich die
Benchmarks einlässt in acht Kerne, ne?
Ja, acht Kerne.
Das ist die neue Generation.
Also, du hast auf jeden Fall genug Leistung.
Das ist, das ist klar.
Hast du einen extra Rützen-Lüfter?
Oder willst du den Box verwenden?
Ist da überhaupt einer dabei?
Ah, ist dabei.
Also, ich schwöre ja auf ordentliche, auf Noctua, Noctua CPU-Kühler.
Gibt nichts besseres und leider auch nichts teuereres.
Festplatte ist eigentlich fast egal.
Ich hab schon seit Jahren hier massig WD-Creens,
wo Terabyte rumliegen, ist bisher nichts kaputt gegangen.
RGB ist ordentlich.
Aber der RAM hat kein RGB.
Da, da verschenkt der RGB.
Option.
Das Ding hat ordentlich Power, ja?
Also, ich persönlich.
Wenn ich schon, wenn ich schon...
Also, du kannst, das Netzteil kannst du ruhig
nur mal kleiner nehmen.
Da brauchst du kein...
Also, kannst du ruhig auch eins, eins...
Aber das macht es im Prinzip auch noch mal aus
bei der Kohle, was das Ding kostet, ne?
Also, ich würd mir eine Noctua-Lüfter drauf machen
noch, weil ich Noctua-Lüfter mag.
Und mir wären zwei Terabyte als Platte zu klein.
Aber der Rest ist rund, ja?
Der Rest ist rund.
Die Problem ist, aber ich, also,
ich würd's mir jetzt nicht einfach so kaufen.
Ich würd noch mal das mit irgendeinem checken,
der, der sich aktuell auskennt,
weil es gibt immer so ein paar Fallstricke,
Fallstricke, die kennt man nur,
wenn man aktuell dabei ist.
Zwei Terabyte zu klein, klar.
Wenn du ein bisschen Shadowplay aufnimmst und sowas,
und Battlefield-Runde hat 25G.
Ich hab, im NAS hab ich dreimal 10TB
und jeweils im Rechner noch mal
einmal, einmal 6TB,
im anderen auch nochmal 6TB.
Muss.
Wo muss der Scheiß dahin?
Wo muss der Kram ja gespeichert werden, ne?
Wie gesagt, Gameplay-Material ist ordentlich.
Was sagst du zur 25 Euro SSD auf Hardware-Rad?
Wird bestimmt was taugen.
Ich glaub nicht, dass er Mist verkauft.
Was ist das für eine?
Bestimmt, bestimmt ne, ne, ne, 500, äh, ne.
Ha.
Hier heißen die, diese MX400,
irgendwas, äh, Mikron,
Dings, da, ah, keine Ahnung.
Gucken wir doch mal.
25 Euro von Hardware-Rad.
Gucken wir mal, übrigens, äh,
ah, nicht, äh, nicht Rate, Rad.
Ah.
Wo hat er denn die SSDs?
Wo ist denn die 25 Euro SSD?
Die da?
Ah ja, die Crucial-Dinger meinte ich genau.
Nicht MXBX.
SSDs kannst du dir im Prinzip, äh,
kannst du jetzt nicht mehr so viel verkehrt machen eigentlich.
Ach so, ne.
Du musst ja nicht Hardware-Rad quasi, äh,
ne E-Mail in seinem Shop schreiben.
Du kannst beispielsweise bei ihm im Livestream vorbeigucken und fragen.
Oder aber du machst, wie viele andere Leute auch,
du fragst mal auf Computerbase.
Also Hardware-Rad habe ich schon gesehen,
der macht, wenn er Livestreams macht,
äh, macht er öfters für irgendwie kleine Donation,
macht er dann auch Kaufberatung im Stream.
Alternativ kannst du natürlich auch einfach zu Computerbase gehen
oder gehst PC Master Race Reddit
und fragst mal, was die von deiner Zusammenstellung halten,
weil ich würde mir auf jeden Fall noch eine Meinung einholen
von jemand, der auf dem aktuellen Stand ist,
was so, äh, Unverträglichkeiten anbelangt, ja.
Es gibt da immer wieder so kleine Sachen,
wo man einfach nicht drauf achtet,
wenn man nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel war es sehr schwierig,
damals durchzublicken, welche Mainboards jetzt eigentlich,
äh, weil die Sockelbezeichnung von Intel so bescheuert war,
für ein 8700K,
das war auch schwierig da durchzublicken,
wenn man nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand war.
Ja, so ein paar Sachen.
Oder wie das zum Beispiel, äh,
in das Gehäuse die Grafikkarte nicht reinpasst von voller Länge.
Das ist alles Beispiele, muss jetzt hier nicht sein, ja.
Oder dass bei diesem Mainboard speziell,
irgendwie unter diesen Lüftertyp,
der Ram nicht mehr passt oder sowas.
Das können ja bloß Leute sagen, die auf dem aktuellen Stand sind.
Ja, guck mal, ich hab jetzt hier drinnen.
Aber man sieht's, glaub ich, gar nicht alles, ne.
Nee, man sieht's gar nicht alles.
Weil die Platten sind alle,
sind alle, äh,
Cripple,
die, äh,
Ich muss jetzt so langsam aber sicher pennen
Wir suchen outro musik
Wobei wir hatten wir hatten wir hatten letztens einen coolen remix davon aber sehr nice
Okay leute also wir sehen uns die tage vielleicht schon morgen macht's gut bis denn
Unser
Copyright WDR 2021